hello welcome to this video playing EU 7
what's you trading up don't have this
big gaps that often okay declines any
ideas over sharp a game with with this
kind of stuff just playing a collie set
up okay we'll see what happens I like
this kind of set up against is just
playing it like hmm yeah the reason I'm
hesitating is that 997 could be
interesting here okay I'm gambling a
little bit i'm not quite sure what to do
okay doesn't really do much here 95 or
cheek first I think I'm doing this oh is
it t giving me the bishop pair here I
mean for not much
you
yeah he basically is right I mean he has
to almost no doesn't so and let's say
90x90 we do we take a couple of times
and then hmm i also have to shop g4 in
this position quite interesting Bishop
f5 if if he takes it then like a million
times at the end I can takes you three
so but I'm threatening III as well so
this is already kind of tricky like if
he cancels i have III yeah in this case
I take it a couple of times in the night
takes c3 at the end let's just quickly
check takes Queen takes and the rook is
hanging yeah check so um just going back
or is there a difference I can go here
maybe keep yourself protected okay so
his intention is kingi to whom yeah
that's understandable maybe I'm like
this and just centralized Bishop f4 I've
Queen to c6
you have this Bishop on f6 is so pretty
annoying peaceful wide b2 is under
attack gen yeah he only has those
passive moves available so i could
actually take them i can take with the
bishop this is sure to do they should
keep the pawn
yeah that keeps the pont from the moment
yeah v6 or a six not quite sure I need
to be a little bit observant about the
clock situation a little bit behind
it's not really threatening all that
much maybe here so that this is actually
protected for Bishop deform should be
for now yeah it's it's certainly
playable I'm not quite sure if it is the
strongest but it looks viable and Scott
a five year
okay let's put up this pin
yeah de porn I can take with the bishop
but what is possible
now let's keep the a porn yeah 11 I one
thing is I can just drop back and play
em put this behind the pawn this when
i'm trying to say the roof behind the
pond but this is also possible first to
check ok let's go behind the pond it
should be should be doable this ok
here's Luke he has nine seasonally it's
a little bit a little bit of knowing
what it should be ok I don't know I
probably could have played this better
some somehow it doesn't feel like the
best possible way of playing
it fell to me that hmm I'm actually in
some kind of super swung here Wow while
I really played this terrible name check
check
Wow and really screwed that up royally
it's still pretty good but I mean it was
a bad idea to put through gonna hate
when the porn is still that far behind I
didn't realize how problematic this
actually is can almost primitive form
yeah I can print word
check
check check check check I check recruit
you for chad is some kind of some kind
of stalemate back check checkmate poor
and the tough thing about games like
this is if you win you get one rating
point if you lose I it's terrible and
really I really didn't do a good
technical job him Jim yeah this is
excellent already threatening him yeah
he took this and then we had this this
secret Jack I think this was okay I mean
this is a technically probably almost
winning position but I really played it
badly with this transformation to the
book ending I'm kind of okay with all
that this is this is all right but now I
should just play it differently just go
a five or something check this or now a
five this is a bad idea I totally
underestimated how active he gets this
is some this is really bad it's two
points and it sits behind but it's it's
nonsense I have to get in at least a
five now it's really difficult
I felt this is actually is a kind of
decent ideas I try to win jack yeah I
think I haven't still have excellent
winning chances yeah I'm winning it was
bad it's behind the porn but that's not
all there is if he gets to blockade on a
six hmm not easy at all that's very good
to remember yeah this is positioning
with luke a6 I really underestimated
that I was kind of thinking okay and
then there should be some kind of win
but hmm it's not really very apparent
what would win there there might be okay
well thanks for watching